okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the distributive property and
simplifying expressions or solving
equations using the distributive
property so let's get right into this
video you probably learned the
distributive property back in algebra 1
but i just want to show you something
that they tend to test us on when we
take the act and let's just go through
these two examples and i'll show you
what i mean so whatever's on the outside
of the parentheses here see because
they're right next to one another that
means they're multiplied together so
what we do is we take this quantity on
the outside and we distribute it or
multiply it however you want to say that
into the parentheses so we have 5 times
2x which is 10x 5 times negative 10
which is negative 50. okay so when you
see a minus sign you can think of that
as a negative number just group it with
the 10
and think of positive 5 times negative
10 is negative 50 minus a negative you
know they're interchangeable so negative
50 minus 50 basically means the same
thing now in this one you can see it's a
negative 5 that we're going to be
distributing into the parentheses
negative 5 times 2x is negative 10x a
negative 5 times a negative 10 the two
negatives give you a positive when you
multiply so that's plus 50. so that's
something that you really want to watch
out for if you have a negative times a
negative it's a positive but remember to
capture that minus sign realize that
that's a negative and it goes with this
number here okay so let's look at a
couple examples see if you can pause the
video
do these on your own and then check your
answers to see how you're doing so
example one it says if 3x equals this
quantity here then what does x equal
okay so what we're going to do here
is we're going to distribute
and so that gives us negative 8
plus 4x right because the negative times
a negative plus 12 and i'm just going to
bring the 3x down
and then let's see i'm going to subtract
4x from both sides of the equation
okay so that gives us negative x equals
negative 8 plus 12 gives you 4 and i'm
going to divide both sides by negative
one so you can see these negatives
cancel and we get x equals negative four
now on the a c t because it's multiple
choice what you could do is you could
take
you know the answers and put them in
to make sure that you know that that's
the correct answer so if you forget or
you don't know how to solve it you can
just take the answers put them in here
and here simplify the left and right
sides make sure that they're equal to
each other you know you've got it right
but it's pretty easy to solve this the
main thing is to make sure that
a negative times a negative is a
positive so let's look at example number
two see if you can do this one
it says the expression two times the
quantity x plus five minus four times
the quantity three x minus two is
equivalent to which of these three here
so see if you can do this one pause the
video and uh we'll go through it
together
so what i'm going to do here is i'm just
going to distribute the 2 so that's 2x
plus 10 right i'm going to distribute
now see this minus 4. i'm going to treat
this like a negative 4 i'm going to
distribute the negative 4. so negative 4
times 3x is a negative 12x negative 4
times a negative 2 is actually a
positive 8.
2x minus 12x is negative 10x and 10 plus
8 is 18.
now just a quick refresher you you want
to just capture the sign that's to the
left of the number the left of the
quantity those are a group and you can
think of these as on little sheets of
paper you can move them around
group the like terms together all these
are added together if you see a minus
sign just think of it as a negative
quantity so positive 10 positive 8
that's how i got the positive 18 here
and then positive 2x negative 12x i
added those together that's how i got
the negative 10x so it looks like the
best answer here is letter b